Puggy's tongue is four and a half inches long,...
...which makes him the Guinness World Record holder for dog with the longest tongue.
It means a great deal to us that he's accomplished what he has.
Coming from being a stray dog, dumped in the country...
...to a Guinness World Record holder is just phenomenal.
It's just, I can't believe it.
What I do for Puggy is I have to chop his food up into really small pieces,...
...which enables him to eat with as much ease as possible...
...since he does chew with his tongue, and he manages just fine.
The reaction I get from people when they see Puggy is just total astonishment...
...because they've never seen anything like this before in their life.
So, he is definitely a head turner and a sight for sore eyes.
He's great.
When we first found Puggy, we had no idea that one day, he would be the...
...Guinness World Record holder for dog with the longest tongue.
It's absolutely amazing.